today's legal minute we are learning if
foreclosure can be stopped with
bankruptcy Eric Palacios from Eric
Palacios and Associates the sponsors of
this segment tell us more
hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the
legal minute today's question is can a
foreclosure be stopped with a bankruptcy
the answer is generally yes if you file
a bankruptcy a stay order will be given
by the trustee this stops the
foreclosure process if you file a
Chapter 7 bankruptcy this day will
usually be lifted and the foreclosure
process can continue you in most cases
will not be responsible for the unpaid
mortgage amount however if you want to
save your house from foreclosure you
will have to file a Chapter 13
Bankruptcy this allows you to make
payments on their rears and keep your
house the same generally applies to the
repossession of a car but you have to
take action quickly before it's too late
it's important to talk to an attorney
about your options and legal rights I'm
Eric Palacios we'll see you here next
time on the legal minute
give Eric Palacios and Associates a call
or visit their website at Eric
palacioslaw.com